this is a better version
they're gone just like that
so we're Pacific baby Pacific time when
you book it's Pacific time you even have
a purple phone case
so I mean blending into your shirt might
as well put in the center there so we
can see it on the screen
I mean QVC QVC we have got a beautiful
purple case let me just show the metal
show it to you here look it's absolutely
gorgeous isn't it hold it a little bit
so it more reflects there we go oh now I
get why they do that because anyway
movies around look at that now you've
got grease stains in the middle that's
from his thumb okay no it's on my
fingers that's from your fingers right
there it's absolutely beautiful look at
that the way you type it you can type on
that that way you can type on the other
way and you'd be so not true you know
but it is absolutely gorgeous it is
coming right now if you buy one purple
case you will get a purple velor shirt
you will get this as supplies last we
only have how many do we have Phil
he's saying we only have a hundred left
we're gonna dock it down we want them to
fly but they're honestly they're going a
little too quick so we're gonna dock
them down we're gonna make them you can
get now you can get these you can get
another version of this
you can get another version of this for
probably a hundred and ten dollars this
is a better version
and we are not gonna give it to you for
a hundred dollars [ __ ] screaming dude
just absolutely outright screaming
here's here's the thing if you want this
for 100 you go to them right Phil you
can go to we can't say the competitors
names but you go we are not going to
give it to you for a hundred dollars we
are not going to give it to you for
ninety dollars we are not going to give
it to you for eighty dollars what we are
not going to give it to you today right
now for seventy dollars
we are not going to give it to you for
sixty dollars
we could give it to you for fifty
dollars but I'm feeling generous we are
not going to give it three minutes for
fifty dollars
we are not going to give it to you for
forty dollars or thirty dollars today
only today while supplies last and I
don't look Phil's telling me not to do
it we are going to give it to you for
four
payments
of 12 cents
and they're gone they're gone just like
that two purple faces so long to get to
the end yeah with the purple velor shirt
also he's you have been doing you yeah
how could you say who when I say you
pointing at you yeah I thought you're
talking about me he I'm like he who he
is me laughing you wow wow [ __ ] wow
he who he who you okay uh so you've been
doing that yeah for can't even tell you
how long 23 years can't even tell you
how long probably 23 or something like
that more maybe 25 years we've got I
would just pick up stuff around the
house look at these glasses okay we've
got and we've got Reese we have these we
and we're gonna get we're gonna give
them where we can't give them we're
gonna practically give them away
to uh yeah you can get this green wall
right now
40 easy payments of two cents well
this is not even worth it you know
that's 80 cents
say postage would cost way more yeah
posts goes away more honestly
uh so you can check on postage
[Music]